disclaimer here this is the first time
we've done this but the name and voice
of the innocent lady you're about to
hear had to be disguised for security
purposes this is a person who is
currently in the process of leaving
Islam is facing real danger and we do
ask that you listen to this entire
interview in its totality to understand
the context and do her story justice
back here Lyda with crowd are so glad to
have this next guest we're gonna use a
code name here code name Q and let me
tell you why it'll make more sense I got
a message on Facebook and I get quite a
few of these but this one really caught
my eye because of the nature of it this
was a young lady who talked about having
watched one of my videos one of the
Quran challenge videos and actually
having gone through a pretty big
transition in in leaving the Islamic
faith so you can imagine that she wants
to keep her identity under wraps her
name is not in fact Q but for today that
is renamed cute thank you so much for
coming on thank you I know it's awkward
using the different I'm here so listen I
got your message so I guess you know
what just sort of I don't want to speak
for you kind of walk me through what
what happened here you were you were you
were Muslim I guess to begin with or
where did it start you know I was raised
Christian my entire life Pentecostal and
most of my friends room was well I would
do a rough patch and I turned to Islam
and at the time I you know I thought it
was exactly what I needed in my life it
came like in such a quick roll flip low
ones in my life and I converted I
converted during Ramadan like that's a
rough time to convert yeah you you NN
with both feet I wasn't living at home
at the time
um wasn't migrated terms with my family
and yeah it was at the time I was where
I really felt like look I felt failed by
Christians and at the time I thought
filled by God you know answer Islam you
know my Muslim friends were the ones
there for me and they kind of took me
under their wing and they were teaching
me things and I really had no idea much
about it at the time
sure um and my cousin was Muslim she
converted scary Muslim man and I was
really at their house a lot and we start
keeping to the mosque and yeah everybody
just like when you walk into a mosque
and you're not mostly that's kind of
like you know right I'll come at you
yeah I can imagine it's yeah big time
yeah
so okay so this happened so I think
that's a story I mean people would argue
that's not necessarily exclusive to
Islam that a lot of people find faith of
any variety when they're when they're in
a rough spot in their life right so for
how long were you practicing Muslim okay
so since 2008 and this was a recent
leaving from the message you see yeah
okay
so no not to sound self aggrandizing you
mentioned that a big a big part of it
was in watching one of my videos that
you yeah
learn some things you hadn't known and
it sort of caused you to explore it a
little more right well in Islam that I
mean I've heard terrible things from
Muslims and you know and it's been from
Islam it's not like you can say oh well
you know anybody's bad but no like
horrible things through some and I
always classes on you know but over the
few tests few months I was feeling like
you know something's not right here
you know seen young girls being forced
in the mirror
all these things and I was just I was
sitting at home and I seen a rebuttal
video of a mobile meet one of yours oh
that's right yet talk Islam we invited
him on the show and no no interest yeah
video that I watched it and I was like
wow I do know some of that stuff about
you know I see you're saying all these
Serbs and I ended up looking them all up
and you know I was asking my texting my
little friends and my husband at the
time you know what Perceval and what
does this one mean and even know I'm
really they just kind of danced around
it you know like well yeah that's true
but you know right thing which isn't
true and so I ended up walking all of
your videos oh geez yeah the more I was
watching the world is like wow like this
is he's so read on you know and a lot of
it I didn't know and so I started
looking it up and whatever in the event
that I decided for myself I was done I
was done there's no way there was no way
I could justify it anymore
you know I had come to a point where
there got to be so many signs that you
know this isn't right like it's not
right it's evil yeah it is it's not
there's nothing peaceful about it
there's nothing beautiful about it well
I guess to the to the people who would
say if that's the case and you see that
now why didn't you see that as someone
who you know it was old enough to make a
critical decision and entered into the
faith what do you think why didn't you
know that then you know and someone I
think I have a lot of common sense and
I'm looking back I ask myself the same
thing why didn't I see it sooner
especially coming from a Christian
family who you know would warn me and
pray for me and all these things and I
was really really searching for
something different from what I was
raised in and I was really angry at God
for a long time and I don't know I think
I just looked at it was well colored
glasses on you know like I would hear
things and I would go to an imam and I
would go to somebody you know this is
what I heard this is what I read in the
comments you know I don't understand
that
you don't necessarily like it you know
can you explain it to me and they would
explain it
and you gotta understand this hold on
one second we have to we have to go to a
break real quick cuz I don't want to cut
you off Lauda was right we will be back
with codename Q after this we are back
with my guest I don't want to interrupt
her quick recap code name Q because she
converted from Islam and is this is the
first time she's she's talking about it
this publicly and you were just telling
us about how you would go when you began
questioning to your Imams and that's the
stage okay sorry continue okay yeah so I
was looking at it one color glasses on
and they would you know just tell you
just because you don't understand it
doesn't mean it's wrong it doesn't mean
it's not right and you know there's a
lot of things we don't understand it was
God and her and I understood and I
accepted but you gotta understand with
Islam there's such a deceptive spirit
that comes along with it and unless you
like experience it firsthand you you
know you wouldn't understand it but it's
yeah you know you got to think there's
all these women that convert to Islam
daily you know I know hundreds of
American women who have converted to it
and there's it's a deceptive spirit
there's something about it you know
people look at it they always feel bad
it's so bad but yeah I wasn't ask you
because you talk about women converting
and you know the trees to tist achill e
there aren't a ton of people who convert
it's it's usually obligatory or
birthrates is how islam is is really
growing but there are some people who
convert what is and forgive me I'm not
asking this to be rude but what good
possibly be the appeal for a woman to
convert something as oppressive as Islam
I mean what's the thought process yeah
they're okay you know I get that a lot
and the thing about it is most of the
time when a girl converts its for man
most of the time you know they we need a
Muslim man who sweeps them off their
feet and they fall in love and they make
you feel protected and they make you
feel special and they tell you all the
time you know we believe that heaven
gana is lies beneath the woman's feet
and you get to heaven through the woman
and I don't I can't explain it there's
this attraction to it where they're
protective and they care and do you
think it maybe might it's also sort of
because listen let's be honest that's
been lost in modern society a lot of men
are just sort of there's a lot of
objectification and you feel like oh
they're they're more gentlemanly what
would that be exactly like some worries
and dad with them you know they here
they treat you like you're a queen on
top of the world you know they treat you
so amazing at first right and then
usually you'll hear like once you marry
the man and start having kids with the
man the changes you know it does doesn't
stay that way that's how they get you
and then and then once you're in it then
you realize you know most people realize
from don't but you realize that it's not
turning that what you signed up for you
know there's no hundreds of girls who
converted and then you know they thought
it was the love of their life and then
they end up getting or getting beat up
everyday and you know I was married and
I wasn't a lot of work I wasn't allowed
to have friends every time I got a
friend he'd find something wrong with
the friend you know I couldn't go
anywhere barely he could even go to a
restaurant you know you and you're
saying thank you Lee because he wanted a
lot of people would say and I can assure
the company would say well that you're
talking
to a woman who left because of a bad
husband and so she's just using it to
tarnish all of Islam that that's that's
an exception that's not the rule but
this isn't particularly common it was
just your case oh is it really really
common and that's the dangerous thing
about Islam and I really feel like that
that's how Islam can start taking really
making this way in this country is there
I mean people don't realize how many
girls convert daily and how many girls
you know like that I think that's how
they're gonna get through this country
is the convert the girls they have tons
of children with the girls and then they
raise those kids well you know I know
hundreds and it happens every day and
it's not it's not uncommon now how do
you no wonder that seems like a very big
number is it because you log into a
network yeah well yeah you know in the
Arab community it's a very tight-knit
community almost everybody knows
everybody come especially in the whisper
women you know if you're going into
you're born or some trim wanna York
those are very high Arab communities um
everybody knows everybody all the women
know each other all the women talk like
you know I know women I talk to women
who live overseas who have never been
here you know you it's a really
tight-knit community okay
wow that makes everybody yeah that makes
I mean that makes sense in Montreal you
know we have that definitely with the
Lebanese community right you always have
you know especially sort of these
multicultural enclaves yeah okay so I'm
sorry I'm just trying it is fascinating
to me and I want our listeners to get
the you know I want them to get the full
scope of your experience and what it's
like and I know what they're going to
say you just have to be prepared when
there's no I know I know
okay well and you've read the comments
if you've no no doubt seen the videos
and I mean listen we've been targeted
not only for acts of violence you know
by Muslims but of course censorship on
YouTube with down votes and trying to
get rid of advertisers so let me ask you
this because a lot of people will say
and I don't think it's necessarily wrong
they'll criticize me even Christians are
saying you know you'll never you'll
never convert anyone with something like
the Quran challenge well let me give you
sort of my logic and you can tell me if
this is what happened with you my logic
is I'm not creating that video for the
guy who creates the talk Islam rebuttal
I'm not creating that video for your
husband where there is no chance of me
congruent but I feel as though when you
have people who are manipulators who who
are proactively lying to their
constituency and I think you see that a
lot with like with Tom Yam if I can make
an example of them and yes be a little
bit biting yes be a little bit vicious
it allows me not to reach them but to
reach people like you who can see there
and be exposed that's my logic is that's
right on yeah okay and yeah and that's
essentially why I wrote you is because I
figured you know I'm sure you get a lot
of hate mail yours was actually
literally sandwiched in between
anti-semitic emails even though I'm not
Jewish from Mossad yeah you know I'm
sure someone like you who does videos
like you do
I'm sure it's nice once in a while to
hear that you reached somebody that you
know you effected somebody in a positive
way through it you know instead of all
the heat meal and that's and you did and
I was very manipulated by these people
for years crazier and and I I really
just need I needed that push you know I
was in another state I had no family no
friends I was a long list my husband my
three kids all I had was his family and
I knew something wasn't right and I felt
it in my heart and I had been thinking
about it for a while and I and I just
needed that extra plus to you know let
me know you know you're doing the right
thing this is this is not right this is
not a good religion this is not
something I wanna raise my daughters in
it's not something I want to be a part
of forever and that's essentially what
it was because you know the things he
talked about I didn't necessarily know
so once I was more informed and you know
had the right questions
I that was it for me you know that was
what I needed and you know God uses
people in different ways and I
personally feel like you use your video
to kind of give me the push I need it
well thank you that's very kind of you I
certainly won't go on and say I am a
tool of God I'm a guy who put on a wig
and a unibrow but I appreciate but let
me ask you this so timeline here you see
sort of asking questions you separated
from your husband did the separation
occur because of the questions that
started coming or was it before that
well here's the thing is when I decided
I didn't tell anybody you know being in
another state have no family no signs no
word to really turn except his family
they don't take kindly to people who
convert and then convert back you know
that's not they don't speak kindly to
that and I was really worried about a
lot of backlash and from them and I was
worried about my kids you know because
legally he could stop me from leaving
the state and so I called my family I
was on what I you know that I wanted to
leave I wanted to get out but I was
scared and they worked with me we we
like kind of made up this reason for me
to have to come home for a while okay
and you know through God's hands they
accepted it and they took it and they
said okay and they let me leave and so I
packed up my kids packed up our things
and last and this was in a matter of
like two weeks and so once I got here my
brother's a lawyer we were talking about
what the next steps I can take you know
well me Mary's islamically but with my
kid you know they don't want you taking
their kid you know is that coming is
that common in this area where you you
only get married under the I guess
Islamic law oh yeah because they have
more than one wife really no did your
husband have more than one wife no he
wanted to or sometime but I fought him
on it but yeah he didn't have one but he
wanted to
Wow I don't hear about that a lot I
would that it's I wouldn't imagine it's
that common in the United States the
stage for the not yet really oh yeah I
know tons of people who have four wives
three wives two eyes yeah someone they
all live in the same house well I I
didn't know it I will say I have to I
will have to try and verify that because
I don't know for sure it's out and you
do sign papers Islamic papers but
they're not legal marriages but to them
they are to them their marriages through
guys so so then we were married like
married married even though we weren't
married on paper Wow yeah that is pretty
pretty common and you know in Islam you
can't get legally married unless you
guys want agree marry first an Islamic
marriage is so easy to just divorce from
it you just need to work three times
then you're gone this no okay come on is
that you actually say to me divorce
divorce divorce and your door
are you pulling my leg here is this I
swear I swear making it sound like the
horror film you say Candyman in the
mirror three times and that guy that the
Burger King kids club haircut appears
yeah and to get Islamic remarried the
woman doesn't have to be further as long
as he has a man there on her behalf she
doesn't have to be there and like when
we got as long as we married I didn't
have to be there like it doesn't even
involve me you don't even say anything
what about what about divorce though
what have you wanted a divorce and he
didn't want a divorce then he doesn't
have to give it to me so you can't say
divorce - three - no only the man can
okay now did you know this when you were
marrying him
yeah I did I was very very I was I was a
fool I was I was a fool I asked myself
that all the time what was I doing
like I look back on it now like god I
was so dumb I well I don't think so I
really don't think so and that's not why
I asked those questions I asked the
questions because listen I I can't
really know this I can know on paper
what the Quran says I can know Muhammad
but learning these these experiences I I
mean that's incredible let me I'd love
to keep you on for another segment here
because there's there's so much to get
into so code name Q Islamic convert be
back after this we are back we were
talking Islamic divorce our guest
codename Q has converted from Islam
it's fast it's it's it's honestly it's
one of those things where it sounds like
something that I need to question and
I'll be honest tough to go go online
afterward and search these things and
say okay how accurate is this because I
know that the audience is going to say
this is just anti-islamic rhetoric I
mean or Osama Sablan II we just did a
piece on him out there in Dearborn
Michigan who said that Pam Geller was
worse than Isis for drawing Mohammed and
when I said that's absurd they accuse me
of being Islamophobic so it seems like
calling anyone including terrorists out
on their actions is now Islamophobia
anyways that was my own little diatribe
my apologies let's get back to you
you're much more interesting so this
divorce happens so you you get it you
find a reason to get out of state and
get your family yeah no but I'm here
I've been here four months and I was
advised by lawyers to not do it yeah to
not tell him and then family not that
I'm done because I have to establish
residency if I don't establish residency
in the state which is this month then he
can take me to court and they can force
me to move back especially since I moved
out technically on false pretenses and
how can they force you to move children
legally I was the resident there I my
kids were born there we were together
there and I left and if you don't get
any like he he can legally go to the
court and say I didn't know he was
leaving for good I didn't want my kids
to leave and they can force me to move
back okay it would sound even though you
weren't legally married he can do that
yeah yeah like if we work just even if
we were just eating and we have a child
together and I wanted my modesty
we would have to go to court and have
legal saying he's okay with that and if
he wanted to fight me on it he could and
so you know having three small kids and
I do believe that we will have
eventually have a custody battle um I'm
just trying to you know do it as smart
as I can and we all my option
oh my brother's a lawyer so he told me
just to wait six months here and then
I'll have established residency yeah and
then you know I can tell them you know
this is what's going on I don't want any
part of it
nice trying to avoid right now right and
well obviously what we're doing our best
to make sure that no no person write
tales are revealed here let me ask you
this because you were very adamant
before we did the interview like no I
don't want I don't want any visual and I
don't want people to know the name what
is your honestly no no sensations what's
your fear if people find out that it's
you and find out that you've converted
and left um I'm scared for my kids you
know um you know I know a girl who her
husband here in America here in Michigan
took her child from her a lot of those
she's never seen them again I'm scared
for my kids and scares for a custody
battle on eard
for them to taking to court and make me
move back and then you know god knows
what could happen you know they're those
emissive things people can say oh you
know anyone is bad people you know you
can be any guy that is abusive or you
know any guy that can turn and you but
when it comes to Muslims sir it's almost
every time that they're abusive or
they're you know they try to hurt you
were the backlash ruin your reputation
you know take their kids from you it's
not an uncommon thing it's more common
than people think it is and with Muslims
when you're leaving Islam specifically
because that's a really big deal you
really have to be careful you never know
what they're capable of you never know
you just never know and especially when
kids like those with me whatever it can
do what they want to me but because I
know through small kids I really want to
make sure that you know I do everything
right legally that they can't come after
my kids that they can't fight me for my
kids that they you know can't hunt them
especially so when we hear the media and
people talk about you know the moderate
Islamic majority in this country they're
lumping people like your husband former
husband right in that category yeah
they're moderate Muslim they're not
extreme of lumps this is the face of
modern Islam but even moderate you know
you never know and and that's what's
scary and and the thing is like people
say like oh not all Muslims will go bomb
somebody or not all Muslims will shoot
something I'll bet extreme that's true
but when you think about it cuz then
when they use their bodies for Allah
when they do something on behalf of
Allah in dying process to them that's
true judgment there's no nothing you're
unhappy because you use your body for
the sake of Allah and you know he's all
right now in Islam there's never a
specific thing that says that you know
there's no grace there's no forgiving
there's no forgiveness there's no loss
all it is is you out when you're
confused with you guys you know like did
you give an austerity you sinned here
you know they just did them God without
your deep looking back and in your
conversion be considered one of the
worst deeds
yeah isn't yeah that's as bad yeah well
what do you think about that there's no
guarantee of heaven but if you use your
body for Allah or you fight for the sake
of Allah or Mohammed or Islam that's a
straight shot to heaven no good think
about that that's scary
yeah in their mindset that if they do
this good come on what heaven will ask
you this let me ask you this because I
want to kind of stand on your personal
story so well yeah
talk about that you know and and you
love theologians they'll debate that on
either side and both sides have valid
points but in your case while you were
married okay so you're you're you're
Muslim you're married differ from
husband did you ever talk about these
things like about about terrorism about
jihad and where did he line up on that
worded his family line up
oh they were al-qaeda and that's the
thing that really I usually always got
me even though I was you know converted
I was a big-time American you know
Republican and all that like that never
came outside outside of the Islam saying
outside of the Islam thing they tend to
be pretty conservative right they tend
to be probably you know mm-hmm well I
remember asking them it was you know
when Isis beheaded all little Christians
and I was living in his mom's living
room with the whole family and I
purposely said was in Kabbalah and
immediately everybody said well they did
it to them first they came under land
first
they attacked them Isis was defending
themselves they're just defending away
against America and they come in their
countries and kill the civilians and the
children and then they're defending
themselves don't they have a right to do
that and I was like really
like seriously sitting here defending
Isis to me and they were like whoa no we
simple think he was wrong but they're
defending themselves everybody can't
heat down then this was Matt and I I was
like wow really just because all these
Christians and you don't see anything
wrong with that you know this is Muslim
and I even have Muslim neighbors who if
you ask them they'll say well Americans
just try and take the oil and America
came in their country / America killing
no people and they have a like the
defendant bottle I tell you what and I
hope you're ready for it cue there's
gonna be backlash to this and people are
just going to say that you're
Islamophobic and you're lying but I will
tell you this I I can't verify what you
said if that's true
because I would imagine when polled most
of them would do an about-face and Eddie
Haskell it and you
great mrs. cleaver and then turn around
and say something else but I will say
this I watched 9/11 happen when I was in
Canada and there there were Muslims who
were not unhappy with it I watched that
happen and most people don't believe me
when I say that they don't believe me
they think I'm just saying so I watched
that happen and a lot of these people
they hated Israel and the Jews hated it
this is where I was raised again it was
multiculturalism it wasn't the United
States so I mean I I was actually banned
from a college for doing some bits about
Muslims at a multicultural fair which
are nowhere near as extreme as the
videos that I've done now so so that's
what shaped my view as an outsider yeah
so essentially that the shaped your view
as an insider it's almost like I don't
know what we're gonna have to have you
back on the program because I want to
hear your progress and and if you do run
into some hiccups I'm sure there are a
lot of people out there who would love
to help you all right I do have kind of
one question for you so you're obviously
very afraid to discuss your conversion
right now for fear of safety of your
children and reasons you mentioned when
you left Christianity for Islam are you
left you know what you were raised yes
did you have that same fear no not at
all I mean I was worried about much the
only being mad at me but no okay no and
and that's the thing with Islam is you
know looking back on it and having been
a part of both religions and don't get
me wrong I won't you know mobile people
you know there's some really great ones
out there and you know 90% of my friends
are Muslims I'm just saying from my
point of view you never know what the
capable of because it's hard where
you're getting them from the religion
you know carry out these acts that are
unthinkable to us but to them they're
not that big of a deal right and and
with Christianity you get the sense of
love and forgiveness and grace when you
walk into a church you feel it
immediately and it's different with
Islam when you do the Muslim prayers and
when you go into a
there's no sense of God's presence
there's no sense of love there's no
there's not that warm fuzzy feeling you
get you know and yeah a church or you
know it not existed even to eight to
even to atheists who are who are
listening here it is important for them
because they're gonna see a warm fuzzy
feeling well even if you don't believe
in God the warm fuzzy feeling you could
explain away as the atmosphere because
of the people in the congregation right
are giving you the warm fuzzy feeling so
either way you're describing to two
different donors yeah sure I can imagine
I I can well geez well listen we will we
will keep you in our prayers will
definitely well you will you come back
on the program and in all setting okay
okay we absolutely want you to and if we
need to put a distortion on your voice
here so you're showing one of those
quarter twenty macaulay culkin and the
talk boy will do it but thank you so
much to you for coming on and okay
fascinating stuff Lata with Crowder will
be more after this break Wow the least
funny interview we've ever done on here
but it's important so we please ask that
you go to louder with Crowder calm check
out the sources and ways to help with
women in a situation similar to cue also
subscribe by clicking my face doesn't
cost anything or watch this video next
to me these videos in this message can
only get out if you keep supporting it
good news is that just means watching
and clicking